the left has a new euphemism you've
heard
of mostly peaceful protesters
but have you heard of mostly unarmed
criminals
well that that's the new one from the
milwaukee journal
sentinel so they've since changed the
headline the original headline
regarded that man jacob blake who
resisted arrest and he had a warrant out
for his arrest and he was
convicted of sexual assault and domestic
violence
and then he reached into his car and
finally the police shot him so
the original headline for this incident
from milwaukee journal central
jacob blake had knife in car
but was otherwise unarmed wisconsin doj
says
as it releases name of kenosha officer
who shot him in the back now
everyone knew that there was a weapon in
this car uh that we weren't able to say
that because
you want to give them the benefit of the
doubt and the story but it was pretty
clear he was reaching in for a weapon
now we know that he was reaching in for
a weapon but other than that he was he
was mostly otherwise
unarmed later they changed the headline
because he got so much
flack on the internet so now it is
wisconsin attorney general josh cole
says jacob blake had knife in car but
would not clarify
if responding officers knew about it
well they don't have to know about it's
not that the responding officers are
mind readers or that they had already
cased his car
the fact is when you're resisting arrest
like that and you're a wanted violent
criminal and you reach into a car while
the cops have guns on you
you can't take that chance you can use
common sense common sense
is not too common anymore meanwhile
while the left is trying to downplay
this sort of violence downplay these
sort of threats
they're they're trying to gin up
violence all around the country in the
form of riots
we will get into life and death on the
ballot i'm michael knowles
this is the michael knowles show
welcome back to the show the democrats
and the
militant arm of the democratic party
these violent riders in the streets
they're getting life and death exactly
backwards they are
they're threatening and damaging life
they are celebrating death
the opposite is true at the rnc the rnc
had an amazing couple of nights
on questions of life and death on
questions
of science and on questions of religion
and philosophy it was
really really excellent stuff which we
will get into
first though my favorite comment from
yesterday from amber
says cnn had to remove violent from the
chiron as the
peace intensified yes that's the uh
i forgot about that one we just talked
about it yesterday but there are so many
of these things
that cnn has this line violent
protesters
in the chiron and then they have to take
it away bring it back with no violence
at all
no violence at all because to use
another mainstream media euphemism
when the protests when the peaceful
protests intensify
they become violent another example that
the left
doesn't know how to use english or maybe
they do know how to use english and
that's why
they're so interested in twisting it we
will get into that
first though i got to thank our friends
over at puretalk so
i know what you think you think that
your cell phone bill always has to be as
high as it is and you're never going to
know the right cost and it's going to
keep going up and up and up and there's
just nothing you can do about it right
why because you want to use the best uh
cell networks right you want to use what
a t verizon t-mobile oh you want to use
all the big ones
and so you're just stuck and you got to
pay a ton of money and that's all there
is right
wrong what if i told you that pure talk
usa uses
the exact same network as one of those
carriers same towers
same exact coverage but costs half
i know that sounds too good to be true i
know you can't believe that
you gotta trust me on this you gotta try
it out you can get right now unlimited
talk text and two gigs of data
for twenty dollars a month not twenty
dollars plus
fifty dollars of fees twenty dollars
done average person right now is saving
four hundred dollars a year
using these guys so why is it so much
cheaper because there's no retail stores
there's no billion dollar a year ad
campaigns there's no value adds to your
contract that you end up paying for
and you only pay for the data that you
need plus that's my favorite part maybe
customer service right here in the us
here's the deal unlimited talk unlimited
text two gigs of data for just 20 bucks
a month all you need to do grab your
mobile phone dial pound 250 say keyword
michael knowles that is pound 250
then the modern parlance it's hashtag
250. say keyword michael knowles when
you do you will save 50
off your first month which is already
gonna save you a ton of money go check
it out
the left uses euphemism
right the austere religious scholar
mostly peaceful protesters peaceful
protests intensify
otherwise unarmed criminals that's what
political correctness is
is euphemism using soft words or
outright
dishonest words to obscure truths that
the left does not want to
to convey to you that's what jargon is
whenever you see jargon in the social
sciences most especially
but in any sort of any field that
becomes politicized they'll use
ostensibly technical jargon to sap all
the life all the imagery all the
vividness out of out of what they're
trying to say
so that you don't know what they really
mean
this is not only done to push narratives
on crime and race although that's what
the milwaukee
journal sentinel is doing right now
that's what the left has been doing with
all of these riots and with coronavirus
too which we'll get to in a little bit
most especially though when the left
uses euphemism like this
they're using it on the issue of
abortion
okay it because abortion is so it's a
little baby and you've got to defend
killing a baby if you support abortion
so you've got to twist language in this
way that is that is so beyond any
realm of reason the rnc
called the democrats out for this in a
way that that had more teeth
that was more vivid than i've ever seen
before at a republican national
convention because they had abbie
johnson
who's a former planned parenthood
employee and she was a real i mean she
wasn't a low-level employee
she was being promoted up the chain she
had been given
the margaret sanger award marcus sanger
founder of planned parenthood
she had been given lots of accolades
they saw her as a future leader of the
organization
and then she realized the reality of
abortion and she left now she's one of
the biggest pro-life
advocates in the country she's the
subject of the movie unplanned
so she laces into margaret sanger she
laces into planned parenthood
and then she spills the beans then she
gives a
vivid personal account of what abortion
actually looks like
later in august my supervisor assigned
me a new
quota to meet an abortion quota
i was expected to sell double the
abortions performed the previous year
when i pushed back underscoring planned
parenthood's public-facing goal of
decreasing abortions i was reprimanded
and told abortion is how we make
our money but the tipping point came a
month later
when a physician asked me to assist with
an ultrasound
guided abortion nothing prepared me
for what i saw on the screen an
unborn baby fighting back desperate
to move away from the suction and
i'll never forget what the doctor said
next
beam me up scotty the last thing i saw
was a spine
twirling around in the mother's womb
before succumbing
to the force of the suction
very difficult to listen to that and
when abby johnson says that or when a
pro-life advocate
says something like that that is merely
describing
what happens in an abortion just
describing the physical process of it
or describing a conversation that
someone has with a physician from
planned parenthood or with an executive
from planned parenthood
we're told oh that's that's offensive
you can't do that you can't talk about
that
that's offensive don't it's going to
make people feel
feel the bads you know it's not going to
make them feel feel good
so it's offensive to describe what
people are actually doing to the tune of
a million babies a year
but it's inoffensive to lie about it to
say it's women's health it's the
opposite of women's health
it's reproductive health it's certainly
the opposite of reproductive health
it's uh the right to choose right to
choose what
having slavery in the country is the
right to choose right committing a
genocide is the right to choose
someone's choosing it what's the choice
who cares about the fact that it is a
choice we're always making choices all
the time
what are you choosing to do that's the
question but this is how the left
manipulates language effectively is
because people don't want to hear
ugly truths that's the point of
euphemism is to use a word that is
that's good that sounds
that sounds gooder it sounds more
pleasant but
the reality is what's key here and abby
johnson
obviously has so much stature and
credibility because she actually saw it
the left they always say they love
science right they always love listening
to the scientists
what if the the scientists have a hard
truth to say
what if people who've seen these
scientific processes have a hard truth
to say
what about when the science is not
convenient moving off the subject of
abortion
onto the subject of coronavirus the
left-wing governors most especially
andrew cuomo worst governor on the
subject in the entire country
has has now decided he's no longer going
to listen to the scientists
we'll get into that one second first i
want to thank our friends over at ring
you know ring will help you keep an eye
on your home
wherever you are you could be in your
home which is helpful you could be at
the office you could be on a beach
you could be anywhere and check in
especially these days when a lot of
people are dropping off maybe more
packages than you're used to
when people's schedules are a little bit
more disrupted there's a thousand
reasons why protecting your home matters
to
you ring has security products for every
corner of your home
inside and out and the best thing of all
of course is you can see it all
in one simple app this is this is
actually my favorite part about ring
one i like that i can trust ring that i
can rely on ring sweet little elise is a
good shot but you don't want to rely on
that
but i love that it makes you feel like
you're in the future you know it's so
convenient even i who am not
particularly good at technology
it's easy i can use it it's not too hard
also i give i give
ring away to my friends who buy homes
and
it's a housewarming gift and the best
part for me it's inexpensive so i don't
need to worry about it i saw
my friend's ring device work just the
other day because she tracks a possum
with it she wants to make sure it's not
an intruder it's usually not i hope so
far it has not been an intruder it has
been a cute little possum
that we've actually seen grown up in
part thanks to ring get a special offer
on the ring welcome kid at ring.com
knowles comes with rings video doorbell
3 and chime pro perfect way to start
your ring experience
plus you get two two-day free shipping
go to ring.com
knowles that is ring.com knowles
so andrew cuomo right now worst
governor in america on this issue of
coronavirus in the lockdowns
he insisted on a 14-day quarantine
if people come in from other states
where he thinks coronavirus is exploding
this is very frustrating to me because
i've got a lot of relatives and friends
in new york
i'm not able to go see them because i'm
certainly not going to quarantine for 14
days i don't have that kind of time
nobody does
so all of this was based on the cdc
guidelines listen to the scientists
except the cdc has now lifted that
guideline
the cdc says you you no longer need to
quarantine it doesn't recommend
quarantining
here's andrew cuomo's response the cdc
reversed its guidance to say people in
close
contact with a covid positive person
don't need to get tested
this is not science it's politics
politics that are dangerous to public
health
it's indefensible so andrew cuomo
expert scientist is now going to lecture
the cdc on science because
he says the cdc's become political so he
a lifelong politician
who's never done anything other than
politics knows much more about science
and is certainly not political is that
it that's the argument he's making
not a very convincing one also he
doesn't know the meaning of these words
public health is political science
and not political science like this kind
of useless subject you study in college
but political science meaning it is
science that has a political dimension
to it
public and political are synonyms
they mean the same thing when we're
talking about how we work together
how we apply certain uh certain methods
certain
certain other academic fields to the
public that makes it political
so obviously the cdc has a political
dimension it's a government agency
but how come when they issue guidelines
that you like it's not political
and when they issue guidelines that you
don't like it is political because
what the left is saying is that politics
is a bad word we have to reduce
politics and what what they want to
assume is just that their political
views
are are objective they're true they're
always good there's no debate
they're actually taking their politics
outside the realm of politics so they
don't have to debate about their stupid
policies
they can just do it and then it's only
the other guy's views though that's
politics and that
not only is that up for debate but
really you you should just reject it
outright you know the knee-jerk reaction
from the left is listen to the
scientists
you know the right sometimes responds to
that too so they'll say
okay the left wanted to listen to
science two weeks ago but now they don't
well i'm
we're sticking strong and saying you
should listen to the scientist i think
that plays into the left's hands
i actually think that it's perfectly
right to listen to the scientists
and listen to the politicians and listen
to the economists and listen to
the military advisors and listen to the
spiritual advisors
listen to religion listen to philosophy
but
more especially listen to religion the
left's head
would explode if you were to say
something like that this was trump's big
mistake early on by the way
when he would have these coronavirus
briefings he would only have
a couple of scientists there he wouldn't
bring in all of the other aspects
of politics and government certainly
there's not
not a chance that you would see a
presidential press conference where a
priest
or a nun or somebody came up and spoke
because
as modern science has developed
questions of philosophy the eternal
questions
and certainly religious questions have
been relegated away
but the only way that we are going to
come to a sensible understanding of our
society
is if we incorporate those fields or the
founders of america knew that
uh we knew that in this country until
50 years ago at most and now we seem to
have forgotten it well one person didn't
forget it
and this was the moment of the
republican national convention
it's probably the greatest moment i've
ever seen at a
political party convention a woman a nun
sister dd bird sister dr
dd bird completely stole the show she
is with little workers of the sacred
hearts she's not only
a sister she's not only a nun she's
a medical doctor she's not only a
medical doctor she's an
army surgeon and she worked with with
refugees for many many years
she actually this this none in a habit
is actually embodying a broader
scope of politics a broader scope of
science of whatever you know whatever
sector you want to talk about
then just about anybody i've seen in the
government
right she checks the box of religious
she checks the box of
military she checks the box of
scientists she checks the box of
practical scientists because she's a
surgeon
she checks the box of patriot she all of
these
things the the left would look at this
woman wearing a a traditional habit
and say oh my gosh she's the most fringe
sector of society no she's more
mainstream than any of you people
and she gave a much broader view of this
issue
that abby johnson was just talking about
of this issue of life and death
on the question of abortion she
acknowledges the most
marginalized people on earth those
refugees all share a common experience
they have been all marginalized viewed
as insignificant
powerless and voiceless and while we
tend to think of the marginalized as
living beyond our borders the truth is
the largest marginalized group in the
world can be found here in the united
states
they are the unborn there it is
the left is always talking about the
marginalized and the oppressed
and the vulnerable nobody is more
marginalized and oppressed and
vulnerable
than babies who are killed in the womb
who have absolutely no means
of defending themselves who are totally
and they're they're killed with at least
with the consent of
the government and their own mothers
that's uh
there is no more there's no more
oppressed group on earth and i love
how uh sister byrne just she just says
these things matter of factly
she explains that not a big performance
and arms flailing everywhere
just very simple she's just telling you
the the truth now
what what the left would say if they
didn't know her biographies they'd say
oh
who cares what does this nun know about
anything we all want to hear from the
scientists well
she gives you the science as a physician
i can say without hesitation
life begins at conception
while what i have to say may be
difficult for some to hear
i am saying it because i'm not just
pro-life
i'm pro-eternal life and i want all of
us to end up in heaven together someday
preach sister yes oh my gosh if we could
elect this woman president it would be
so great
she's got this view that she has the
expertise right
she obviously has medical expertise
she's a doctor she's got this practical
expertise
she's a surgeon so she can speak but
she's not locked into her field of
expertise
she's not she doesn't have blinders on
you know
one of the problem with public health
officials is they might know some
usually they don't know anything about
public health but sometimes they do
the trouble is society and politics is
about more than just making sure people
never get the sniffles
it there actually are other dimensions
you have to wait and she's weighing
those things she goes look i'm telling
you about
life it's a physical process i'm also
telling you about eternal life as a
spiritual process
and you have to think about those things
because we're not just flesh we're not
just meat puppets we have a soul we have
an immaterial dimension to us everything
we love and care about love itself
is immaterial right our dreams our hopes
our loves our joys our ambitions all of
these things
they're not physical they can't be
measured under a microscope
someone has to speak to those as well
and then
sister byrne goes a step further she
goes even beyond the fields of science
and religion which are
complementary to one another she goes
further she gets into politics
donald trump is the most pro-life
president that this nation has
ever had defending life at all stages
his belief in the sanctity of life
transcends politics
president trump will stand up against
biden harris
who are the most anti-life presidential
ticket ever
even supporting the horrors of late term
abortion and infanticide
because of his courage and conviction
president trump has earned the support
of america's pro-life community
moreover he has a nationwide of
religious standing behind him
you'll find us here with our weapon of
choice the rosary
so thank you mr president we are all
praying for you
thank you mr president thank you sister
byrne
yes donald trump is the most pro-life
president in american history and i know
a lot of people
a lot of religious people they don't
want to say that they
the the american religious life has been
utterly castrated
since the johnson amendment since we're
not now not allowed to speak about any
matters that have any practical bearing
on politics in churches lest they lose
their tax-exempt status
we're not allowed to discuss religious
matters in schools we're not allowed to
pray in schools which
we were in the united states from the
founding since before the founding
all the way up until not so long ago
we're not even allowed to read the bible
in schools anymore
doesn't make any sense does it sister
byrne however
is not going to be neutered like that
she's going to come right out
and say it it's not just that trump is
the most pro-life it's that biden and
harris
are the most anti-life candidates in
american history
on a mainstream level they want to
force taxpayers to pay for abortions
should there be any limits on abortions
no none according to the biden harris
ticket
and she's out there to say it and i
think we should all learn something from
that
it's this it's this intersection it's
this coming together of all these
various fields that's so wonderful here
it's this integrity of her thought that
the science informs the religion the
religion
informs the science both the religion
and the science inform the political
i'm sure you could expand that further
she obviously has a powerful mind
and spirit so i'm sure this brings comes
out into other fields and then brings it
back together
in an integrity of thought that's
something that's something that we could
all learn from you can tell i'm very
excited by this speech it was a
wonderful speech
and it threw into stark contrast these
issues of life and death so the left
will burn down
the country if a criminal dies while
resisting arrest and we've seen multiple
examples of this
in recent months but the left will cheer
on the slaughter of 1 million innocent
babies per year
it's a little odd isn't it i don't even
i don't mean just to castigate them and
say the left is
they're all just terribly malicious i'm
saying
to be charitable about it their view of
life and death is
is completely backwards they've got some
things off in their perspective
i'll give you another example of this
misunderstanding life and death
there are new court documents that are
out right now dated may 26th
and june 1st relating to george floyd
george floyd the the man who died
in police custody in minneapolis he
wasn't i mean he was on the ground
the police were arresting him he had
been resisting arrest then he was on the
ground
and and very sadly he died and this
sparked
all of these riots you know that we've
been dealing with for the past several
months
so the question is was george floyd
asphyxiated
was he choked to death you know they
always talked about the police officer's
knee on his neck
and george floyd said i can't breathe i
can't breathe now meanwhile let's not
forget george floyd also was yelling i
can't breathe even before the officers
really touched him when he was resisting
arrest earlier in and around his own car
so that this it was it was difficult to
believe it at the moment because he had
already been saying it for a long time
but the chief hennepin county medical
examiner dr andrew baker
now according to these new documents
concluded that george floyd likely died
from a fentanyl overdose and found quote
no physical evidence suggesting that he
died of asphyxiation
they said that if mr floyd had been
found dead in his home or anywhere else
and there were no other contributing
factors he would conclude that it was an
overdose death
we'd been hearing about this for a while
george floyd despite the mainstream
media's
whitewashing to the contrary had been
there not only resisting arrest
but was also on a insanely high dosage
of illegal drugs very powerful drugs
that people die from every single day in
this country
now because he was obviously
under this intense stress you could see
his behavior was so erratic even from
the moment that the cops came and
knocked on his window
it was so intense and erratic that that
may have contributed some to his death
the fact that he was on the ground
and the cop had his knee on his neck
that may have contributed to some of the
stress
that then caused his death you can't
take out of that the fact
that he was on apparently possibly a
lethal dose of fentanyl already
doesn't matter the left doesn't want to
hear that they're going to erase it
they're going to force
the medical examiner to change his
conclusions which is
which is what has happened here the
medical examiner did now conclude
otherwise
the left is out for blood despite
the sign of the scientists right this
guy the medical examiner is obviously a
scientist
the left is out for blood and they're
attacking anybody that they can
to vent their rage an elderly man
elderly man was just defending a
business in kenosha wisconsin
that's the new state that the democrats
set on fire he was attacked during a blm
riot
he was trying to stop a mattress store
from being burned to the ground this man
is in his 70s
and take a listen what you can hear on
this
cut is when the riots go from
the larping you know the live-action
role play
the apparent euphoria among these riders
of just
burning things to the ground to
realizing wait a second innocent people
might be hurt here
to a real terror when this innocent man
is hurt when they go and knock him out
take a listen
this poor man got his his business
caught on fire
so you can hear this i'm sorry sir i'm
very sorry you hear this
yeah really this person's pretty
concerned
who's filming dude i'm going to help
this guy i don't get
if i get beat up so she realized gosh
this isn't this isn't a good situation
she walks over there this guy's got a
fire extinguisher
he just starts spraying the the riders
start throwing things at the 70 year old
man
they just threw a bottle at this guy
but he's got the fire extinguisher there
one cause they're trying to set the
place on fire
now he's spraying the riders there one
goes over
knocks this guy out knocks him down on
the 70 year old man
or in his 70s might be older and this
young criminal thug
degenerate comes over knocks him out
very hard to watch that they broke his
jaw he had lacerations to his head
what did he do he was trying to defend a
business that they were looting and
burning to the ground
and yet we're told by the left that
those
criminals those people who have no place
in a civilized society
they're the good guys and that 70 year
old man trying to preserve
business society law and order
civilization that that man he's the bad
guy they could have killed that guy
maybe they did i don't know i mean we
know they broke his jaw you know he
didn't look like he was in good shape
seems to still be alive though that's
how upside down it gets
sean king blm activist very prominent
blm activist
he's now uh he's now threatening the
lives of
of uh police officers here he writes on
twitter
to the kenosha police department if you
do not name the officer who brutally
shot jacob blake on sunday
we will simply begin naming officers
from your department who may or may not
be him
effin your protection of his identity is
unethical what's his name
so he's saying basically we're gonna
we're gonna dox all of the cops and
encourage people to go attack them right
that's i don't think i don't think he's
going to name the cops so that people
can throw them a birthday party
so that they can do them violence
even though from all of the evidence
that we have
the use of force on jacob blake was
completely justified completely
justified
this isn't the first time sean king has
done something like this
he has a history of making false
accusations in april 2019
he linked robert paul cantrell who was
being held in jail on robert e charges
to the murder of a seven-year-old black
girl jasmine barnes called him a racist
violent a-hole
his words cantrell then later committed
suicide in his jail cell after his
family received a torrent
of awful hateful messages that were
sparked by
by sean king's accusation he doesn't
care what a sociopath this guy is
all of these people imagine
knocking out a 70 year old man because
he's trying to defend a store
not even using he's not he doesn't even
have a weapon he's got a fire
extinguisher
imagine that kind of stuff of course i
mean
if you if you're a member of a political
party that is defending the whole sales
slaughter of innocence
one million per year babies little
babies in their mother's wombs
how could you not engage in a
sociopathic politics
but we're not supposed to say that we're
supposed to use euphemisms
really really nice you otherwise unarmed
the the guy who knocked out the the
threw uh threw a bottle at the
the 70 70 year old man otherwise unarmed
knocked him out but otherwise unarmed
this gets to a question of of white
guilt
because you know the the unifying
message
of the riots has been race black lives
matter and
we have to be anti-racist but what that
really means is that all white people
are racist
someone's summed this up very well a
prominent twitter account said if
were white and not ashamed you're a
racist
and i i think that actually sums up in a
pithy way
the view of the left obviously that is
ridiculous
if you're white and you're not ashamed
you're a racist why would i be ashamed
of
the color of my skin i actually i'm you
know a little bit swirly so i don't
sort of like if if you're beige and not
if you're taupe if you're off-white
you're a little sicilian and you're not
ashamed you're a racist obviously that's
ridiculous
the response to this though is not i
think to shame
white people less i think it's to shame
all the other people more right i don't
i don't think the problem in our culture
is that we have too much shame obviously
people are
very ignorant people are ashamed of
america and of western civilization and
the color of their
skin i mean that's obviously stupid and
people should not do that
but we we don't have a super abundance
of shame in this culture that's that's
certainly the case i think the kind of
the kind of dumbest view on this whole
issue is that white people should feel
guilt because they're white
that's extremely dumb and stupid uh i
think that a slightly
more enlightened view here is
that uh all people should feel ashamed
because we all have a broken human
nature and all have fallen short of the
glory of god and all men sin because we
we're broken and we're not going back to
the garden of eden anytime soon
but i think the best view here and this
is the view that has animated
our entire western civilization is
to quote saint paul as one man's
trespass led to condemnation for all men
so one man's act of righteousness leads
to acquittal
and life for all men
that's the happy ending that's the good
news redemption
it you know the left actually intuits
something when they
when they think of white guilt
in this very narrow way the left
realizes that
some people have
a flawed human nature
right i guess that's the most that's the
most some people have a flawed nature
they're born
broken now what their view is wrong
because they don't realize that this is
true of all people
right and then the view is especially
wrong because they don't realize there's
such a thing as redemption there's no
redemption in leftism
there's no there's no way out other than
to to burn down the cities there's
because there's no
way to be redeemed you've just got to
tear everything
to the ground and that's what we're
seeing happen all around us what do we
do about it i will get into before we
get to the mailbag i will get into
this case of kyle rittenhouse he's a 17
year old teenager
who defended himself in these riots and
is now
going to be charged with murder if he
hasn't already
i think both sides are kind of getting
this issue wrong so we'll get into that
in one second first though i got to
thank you
for subscribing to mike and all show
youtube channel we are now over 190 000
subscribers that's great
appreciate it uh backstage is coming up
this friday we'll be talking all about
the rnc should be fun
and then tonight tonight get ready
tonight at 8 15
eastern 5 50 in pacific i will be live
streaming the final night of
rnc speakers including president coffey
himself donald
j trump i will be watching with you our
all access members taking your questions
and comments live
you know there are a ton of benefits of
being an all-access member so head on
over to dailywire.com right now
dailywire.com knowles get 20 off all
access and two leftist years tumblers
with coupon code access dailywire.com
coupon code access get 20
off your membership we'll be right back
with one more story
and the mailbag
i've got to get to this kyle rittenhouse
story because it's kind of taken over
the internet and the public discourse
about about these riots in wisconsin
right now
so kyle rittenhouse 17 year old
kid you know teenager has been arrested
by police for first degree murder
he he turned himself into the police
yesterday why we actually played a
little bit of this clip just sort of
offhand yesterday
uh kyle rittenhouse was walking around
during these riots and he had an ar-15
and a group of these rioters came up and
started really attacking him
and he defended himself take a listen
you see one guy kick him in the head
so then rittenhouse takes out his gun
and start shooting people
and then the mobsters who are trying to
attack him
go away that's the purpose of a firearm
that is the purpose of self-defense we
have firearms a right to firearms in
this country
because of self-defense
so he shot at least two blm rioters
one of those riders by the way you're
probably not going to see this on the
mainstream media one of those riders
attacking him
had a gun and is a convicted felon
so this is you forget about mostly
otherwise unarmed
this is as clear an example as possible
that this kid used his gun right by the
way the kid's a good shot
so the kid was he didn't he wasn't
shooting 10
000 bullets all over the place he wasn't
he was very precise and he
was able to get his attackers away from
him so the basic take on this i think is
self-defense it's very clearly
self-defense here
but it's not quite as simple as all that
there's there apparently he may have
shot his gun
earlier and then people are reacting to
that
so we don't we don't have great video
from from that
we don't know exactly was that in
self-defense too this clearly was was
that was he just out looking to snipe
people
from this video that seems unlikely
because he's got such good
discipline with his gun however i think
the self-defense argument is it's not
quite as simple because
this guy walked into a provocative
situation with a gun
he he came here to this riot with
a gun now he says he wanted to protect
people right but other people might say
he was looking for trouble
if you you know leave your guns at home
son don't take your guns to town boy
don't take your guns to town
very wise words but it's not quite as
simple as all that
that he was looking for trouble and he
should have left his gun at home and
stay home played video games
because no longer can we rely
in many places on the civil authority
the civil authority is telling the
police to stand down
they've lost control of multiple cities
in the country
anarchy is raging everywhere so if
i'm more than happy to let the cops take
care of things and i don't have to pick
up my gun
but if the cops can't take care of
things if the civil government is not
going to insure law and order and
protect
our lives and property then we have to
protect them ourselves
it's just how it works another another
good reason for the second amendment
so what's the answer here what's the
answer
seems to me it was a bad idea for this
kid to take the gun out and go to this
place
it's ruined his life right he's going to
be charged with murder he might well be
convicted 17
17 years old as a political matter now
this is all anyone's going to talk about
they're not going to talk about
the actual marauding criminals who
started the whole thing and were burning
the city to the ground over nothing
over cops doing their job
when a violent criminal sexual assailant
domestic abuser was resisting arrest and
then reaching into
a car that had a weapon in it but
otherwise was mostly unarmed
it it from a personal standpoint it was
stupid
from a political standpoint it was
stupid it may have been somewhat
courageous but the line between courage
and recklessness
is a little bit blurry sometimes one has
to have prudence
and i just i i hope we should defend
this kid for
from what the evidence that we have we
should defend him because it was clearly
self-defense in that video
but on the other side we should not
encourage people to be doing this sort
of thing
it's completely counterproductive it's
what the left wants it's what the left
is trying to provoke
they're trying to provoke any kind of
right-wing violence here
so that they can focus on that through
the election which is what all of this
is about this is all about the election
they're willing to see people die for
the election they're willing to keep the
economy
completely shut down which will cause
suicides and overdose deaths it already
has
to win an election what will that
election what's what's the sacred right
of that election
what is the issue that the left holds
more sacred than anything you see this
in the
court judicial confirmation hearings you
see it in
in all of the debates the right to kill
a baby in the womb
they're all connected there is an
integrity of thought we talked about
integrity of thought with sister burn
there's an integrity of thought here if
you're willing to let cities burn to the
ground if you're willing to steal
people's property whether
through violent thugs or or the
government coming to your door
if you're willing to allow people to die
break a few eggs to make an omelet if
you're willing to kill babies in the
womb there is an integrity of thought
that presents a
world view that is
that in a certain sense is coherent it
all fits together but when you
look at human nature when you look at
who we are what we're here for how we
got here
it's completely incoherent those are the
choices
not every election not every political
situation
presents choices on life and death as
clear as that but the choice is clear
let's get into the mailbag in our
remaining few moments that i have
i have pushed to the very limit from
thomas besides abortion what other
reason should
prevent catholics or religious people
from voting for biden harris thank you
and love the show
well another big issue obviously
abortion's a big one you're talking
about killing a baby in the womb we've
been talking about it for a lot of the
show
another big issue is socialism now i
don't think joe biden would call himself
a socialist i don't think harris
would call herself a socialist but biden
and harris are not
real people in the sense that they're
not
they weren't chosen because they've got
some distinct personality and a distinct
point of view they are empty suits
blowing in the wind who are chosen to be
the vessels of progressivism
and progressivism clearly has trended
toward socialism
aoc right is the most prominent
socialist in the country and the head of
the democratic party tom perez
chairman of the dnc said that aoc is the
future of the democratic party
and catholics cannot vote for socialism
they can't you know you can read many uh
papal writings on this
rey room navarome a quote apostolici
munaris you can read the catechism of
the catholic church
socialism is not
tolerable for catholics i i think it was
pope leo the 13th who referred to
socialists
as a pest a plague a wicked confederacy
that seeks to steal the gospel itself
it's a false religion it's a parallel
and false religion
based on a false anthropology a false
understanding of man and god
that catholics cannot uh support and if
they do they will be imperiling
their own lives and you know we're
pro-life and we're also pro-eternal life
from dan michael long time fan recent
cigar enthusiast
was wondering if you had any barber pole
wrapped cigars
and if so what are your favorites and
thoughts on them
i recently had the dirty hooligan by
alec bradley and thought it was a great
mild treat love the show despite what
clavin may say about you keep your head
up
he spelled clavin with an e i actually i
spell clavin e-e-e-e-e-e-e-e-e
uh i have i l so every christmas i buy a
barber pole
cigar it looks it looks like a candy
cane like a delicious tobacco candy cane
but i i don't order them that's one
cigar that i don't order from
kind of the big companies because i've i
don't know i've found some of the more
mass produced ones are not as great like
if i'm gonna
if i'm if i'm gonna go to my favorite
cigar website thompson
you know i'm gonna get just the more
kind of standard cigars and
you know anything from the kind of more
inexpensive end
all the way up to the really top shelf
stuff the barber pole ones are a little
more novelty i get them in the bronx
where
you know when i was growing up we would
do all of our grocery shopping in the
italian neighborhood of the bronx called
arthur avenue
best neighborhood left in new york and
uh
you they would have in there a store
called la casa grande cigars
which is in the ortho avenue meat market
i've been smoking cigars there since i
was 15.
when i was under 18 they obviously
couldn't sell them to me so they just
like give them to me right off the table
and they're great and they make a really
good one so i'd recommend if you do find
yourself
in the bronx anytime especially around
christmas go try that one out
from sarah i have a question that seems
to be getting more and more serious
if i were confronted or assaulted and i
fight back or fire shots at the attacker
i may be the person who goes to jail is
it better to roll over and hope the
attackers show mercy
or should i defend myself and hope the
judge isn't a progressive criminal who
will face fire on his own judgment day
it's funny we were just talking about
that if you've got to defend yourself
defend yourself
i wouldn't think too much about this i
wouldn't let the left
make you roll over and hand over your
life
to violent marauders unless there can be
some spiritual benefit to that you know
turning the other cheek in a defiant and
personal way sure
maybe doing some productive good
but as a general rule it is a
well-established moral principle that
you have the right
to defend yourself and i would defend
yourself if you're really a risk
but i wouldn't go looking for it i
wouldn't put yourself
in that kind of a provocative situation
necessarily because
you you know that the the establishment
is stacked against you the whole
establishment
the media the universities the
government the the judiciary the all of
it big tech which is going to control
the flow of information
all of that is stacked against you and
so you know it's very important to be
wise as a serpent and innocent as a dove
you've got it there's there's nothing uh
there's nothing moral about being
foolish
you want you want to be a little clever
about it you want to you want to be
prudent
from alona dear mr knowles can you
please explain to a non-christian how
you're supposed to love your enemy
is it possible to love your enemy if you
don't believe in jesus
thanks you're my favorite daily
wirehouse that's very kind i don't know
if it's possible to love your enemy if
you don't believe in gene
in jesus probably not
but i'm sure some people who think they
don't believe in jesus
or who don't explicitly believe in jesus
would say that they can love their
enemies and they'll use some kind of
vague humanitarian language
but what they don't realize is that
vague humanitarian language comes
directly from christianity
and it's just been watered down and made
less coherent over the
centuries so you know that that case i
think is just an example of
very very watered down christianity
where people don't know why they do the
things that they do
the reason to love your enemy is because
one because of human solidarity
and and human dignity all men are made
in the image of god
all men you can think about the
declaration of independence the equality
principle
all men are created equal in that all
men are equally men
right we're all made in the image of god
so that would be one reason you are part
of humanity you're not just a floating
atom out there
so you are part of humanity and so you
you can love your enemy in as much as
he is part of the humanity that you
share and
because there but for the grace of god
go you
right all men are fallen we do no one
has a perfect nature
walking around earth right now and all
sin and fall short of the glory of god
so because i know that i sin
and the consequence of sin is death
and i'm not even making a prescriptive
statement here though i suppose i am
as well but i'm making a descriptive
statement we have death in the world sin
and death have pervaded the world
as a result of the fall so because
sin is deserving of death
we recognize that we have something in
common with this enemy
now the good news is there is redemption
here
because you because one man sinned and
then
all men died and then one man died so
that all men could live
jesus and we should be very wonderful we
should be very happy about this this is
wonderful
news and we should extend that same
grace that we were given
to the the people who offend us we have
offended god we owe a debt to god
he has forgiven us but he will only
forgive us in as much as we forgive
others this is the lord's prayer right
our father heart and heaven and hallowed
be thy name they can come they will be
done on earth as it is in heaven give us
the stare of daily bread and forgive us
our trespasses as we forgive those
who trespass against us this is a
matter that should come obviously as a
fruit of the spirit but also
it should just come rationally because
we know that we have been forgiven a
much larger debt against
a much more perfect being than than we
will have to forgive
we imperfect beings maybe i hope that
sums it up
let me know i can try to go and you know
we can talk about this for a very long
time but
i hope that clears it up if not right
back in again we'll we'll get into a bit
more
final question andy hey michael you know
quite a bit about theology
so you probably picked up on this trump
mentioned in a fairly funny remark the
other day that biden is hurting god
we all know that biden and the other
catholic or otherwise christian
democrats
definitely advocate against many core
teachings of the church
now during the dnc the media and other
democrats are referring to biden as a
lightbringer
i seem to remember a certain fallen
angel whose name means lifebringer i
don't believe that joe biden is the
devil or anything like that it's simply
astounding how the democrats can
unintentionally parody themselves so
precisely keep owning those lips well
great point and you know it's funny this
i
didn't really intend for it to be this
way but it's obviously a very religious
show but i hope
i like to think there's some integrity
of thought going from the political and
the cultural
scientific whatever up to the religious
that's a very funny coincidence he
they're all referring to him as the
lightbringer he's going to bring light
and lightbringer is
another name for lucifer for satan
this is the thing about a religious view
of the world i mean i would say
specifically a catholic view of the
world you could say christian more
broadly
and and in this desiccated culture even
if you have any religious sense you will
see this
the world becomes very symbolic you see
symbols in places
you realize because because you're
talking about
the deeper meaning of the world the f of
the physical world
you you can see in physical objects
symbols of other things
you can see coincidences all around the
world there's a great line from
alexander pope
which is used as a as a blurb
on uh my friend father george rutler's
excellent book coincidentally and the
line is all nature is but
art unknown to thee all chance
direction which thou canst not see
and when you see a coincidence like that
where the democrats are basically
admitting we're doing the devil's work
you should not ignore that because i
think it's probably telling you
something all right i'll see you
tonight i'm going to be hosting the rnc
all access i'll see you tomorrow
on backstage and i'll see you monday i'm
michael knowles it's the michael knowles
show
[Music]
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies
executive producer jeremy boary
supervising producers mathis glover and
robert sterling
technical producer austin stevens
assistant director
pavel wadowski editor and associate
producer
danny d'amico audio mixer robin
fenderson hair and makeup
nika geneva production assistant ryan
love
the michael knowles show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire
20 20. if you prefer facts over feelings
aren't offended by the brutal truth and
you can still laugh at the insanity
filling our national news cycle we'll
tune in to the ben shapiro show we'll
get a whole lot of that and much more
see you there